now watch who's lost their minds and
what they're doing and how hypocrisy
gets exposed can you pull up uh Alyssa
Milano's tweet and then what the Hodge
twin said to him to her I don't know if
it's him or her I think Alyssa Milano's
uh her
um definitely her I don't want to offend
her uh Alyssa Milano says I give my
Tesla back I give back my Tesla I bought
a VW EV I love it I'm not sure how
advertisers can buy space on Twitter
publicly traded companies products being
pushed in alignment with hate and white
supremacy doesn't seem to be a winning
business model Hodge twins Volkswagen
was literally founded by Nazis and
Hitler and that gets 173 we didn't do
our homework and then Elon Musk laughs
and you see what happens there this is
the best part when people open their
mouth all of a sudden
um you're able to filter out through
people's bullshits and this is why
Twitter is winning today and Alyssa
Milano is trying to find the smallest
hole in the world to go hiding so people
can't find her there isn't anything more
embarrassing than this if we had a dummy
of the week segment this is we this
could be the dummy of the Year segment
although there's a lot of other people
that are competing with her what do you
think about this posted a lot of dummy
of the Year events there's a World Cup
we're going on right now you know with
the whole mask wearing thing too I mean
I've talked to plenty of doctors be on
closed walls you know closed doors and
they said I know the masks are useless
we all knew that was I mean it was just
crazy you know walking to restaurant
where it's sit down you can take your
mask off really so I guess in the booth
I'm safe I'm getting coffee I mean the
whole hypocrisy and she showed one that
she I guess she crocheted her own yes
because I'm it's just uh but you know
it's it's it's it's what that's it's out
there now and people do this kind of
stuff I'm on Twitter please follow me on
Twitter I do very funny Twitter
sarcastic twitters and uh so at K sorbs
because my buddies call me sorbs I'd K
sorbs check it out I posted stuff like
you know you want to get rid of kova
tell the clintons covet's got something
on them that was one of them I put out
there I said fetterman fetterman and um
Biden for 2024. it's a no-brainer I mean
that's kind of stuff I put out there so
to me I just have fun with it and you
got through trolls out there attacking
every time but I don't care I I feel
sorry for you trolls I really do I hope
you get your lives together and actually
find purpose in your life but but again
this is a great thing about capitalism
okay somebody like a musk comes and buys
Twitter people lose their minds but
here's where I believe the connection is
with Disney with apple with Twitter and
this is deeply concerning let me kind of
give you an idea what my worry is here
so Elon so first of all MPR let me read
the article with the 50 advertisers if
you want to pull that up the article
about 50 advertisers uh you put on a
different section let me see what that
is Page 10. okay if we go to page 10
here's a story about what's happened
with Twitter okay if you want to pull it
up so the audience can see this 50 of
Twitter's top 100
advertisers have pulled out from the
platform since Elon Musk took over
Reports say this is an Insider story
uh in the 25 days since ilamas took over
Twitter half of his top 100 advertisers
stopped advertising on the platform
according to research center Media
Matters again Media Matters since 2020
those 50 companies have accounted for
nearly 2 billion dollars in advertising
Revenue this year alone they spent 750
million dollars those 50 companies
that's a big number by the way the some
of those companies like Chevrolet Ford
Chipotle have publicly announced that
they were stopping advertising on
Twitter media matter says the others
quiet quitters because it's analysis of
pathmatics data shows that they have
stopped advertising for a significant
period of time Coca-Cola Kellogg's meta
and amongst
are amongst those who have pulled their
advertising budgets away from Twitter
according to Media Matters the list of
all 50 is available in Media Matters
report the media center cites direct
Outreach controversies and warnings from
media buyers as causes behind those
companies decisions so now 750 million
dollars going to 2 million dollars
Revenue this year on 750 million dollars
let's do the math 750 million dollars
divided by 12 is what about 60
two million dollars 62 million dollars
divided by eight dollars uh is what 62
divided by eight so 62 divided by eight
is nine million seven million divided by
eight you need
7.75 million people per month to pay
eight dollars a month to match that 750.
that's not a big number here's what's
scary listen all the advertisers if this
guy pulls off
20 million people paying eight bucks a
month if 20 million pay eight bucks a
month he can give the middle finger to
the advertisers it's game over from
there because he no longer needs their
money order your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody